let's get into the power rankings
speaking of stupid because uh i expect
to be called stupid and worse by
you and by anyone else out there who's
reacted to these but
shake up at the top this week
christopher oh i've said it before if
the steelers lose what's gonna happen
they're not just falling to number two
baby
you've lost there's a team out there
that's won nine in a row the saints jump
to two
and the chiefs move to one the steelers
fall to three
and what a coincidence this weekend
number three
and number four prime time on nbc to
determine who belongs
in the third spot assuming the chiefs
and the saints win and oh by the way
next week the chiefs and the saints we
got some great
this is like some of those weeks where
the college schedule
pits the best against the best in the
regular season and how that happens so
rarely
that's what the next two weeks feel like
yeah it definitely does i mean i'm glad
you you finally got the kings back where
they
belong i mean they're they're the best
team in football i'm i'm not backing
down from that
um and yes you've been calling this for
a while i mean the steelers have been
hanging on by a thread
i i i think we've we've all seen that
especially the last few weeks and the
chiefs
you know chiefs we have the great
confidence of even when they don't look
great we just we've seen them look great
in big games and big moments so we we
don't doubt them
the saints have been the most consistent
team in football since week three
there's been nobody better and they've
progressively
have gotten better in all areas to where
they're dominant in quite a few so
i'm i'm with you there i mean how much
let me ask you this just right at one
and two
right how close is that like if chief
saints super bowl happens and let's say
drew brees is healthy right
it's it's it's let's just say he's
totally good but like how close is that
where's the spread for you right now as
we sit here in early december
uh i i would say right now chief's five
and a half
you think it's that much the point
spread yeah yeah okay yeah
i would have probably said maybe four
and a half four and a half to five and a
half
okay yeah you think they're that big of
a a
a vegas darling and just that good and
dominant that they'll have that kind of
spread against the saints
i just wonder how much influence there
will be from
the saints recent trend of the
spectacular struggle
coupled with the chiefs trend
of spectacular wins and
the chiefs had their three big moments
in the same post season the saints have
had
their three awful moments spread out
over three years but
you know it's the team that always finds
a way to win and the team that always
finds a way to lose
and i think that in the postseason it's
a good point mike
and and that that i think that's going
to influence people if and when those
two crossed paths
in the postseason we'll know what the
point spread is soon enough they're
playing at the saints
i think the chiefs game at the saints i
think the chiefs will be
two and a half point favorite yeah okay
all right yeah that would be i
actually with what you said i kind of
agree with it i think you you might be
right there
all right so you got those top two tell
me about
the next two in the bunch how close were
you with green bay
and buffalo i mean that that's an
interesting one aaron rodgers green bay
been
pretty good football buffalo's on fire
uh i was i'm you know i'm surprised you
have them in front of
green bay but the bills were so damn
impressive on monday night
on a big stage and they've got three of
their next four games
on that well two of their next three now
they've already passed the first test
but they have a sunday night game
against the steelers they have another
prime time game coming up and if they're
ready
to play at a high level in a big spot
that that means something to me and look
we expected the packers to beat the
eagles
but we both picked the 49ers to beat the
bills the fact the
won as handily as they did that that
gives them uh extra points and and i
actually thought about putting the bills
ahead of the steelers
going into this sunday night game
because i'm probably going to pick the
bills to win that game
and we've used that as a litmus test in
the past to determine who should be
higher
i think that you know we're a day away
from the megapixel podcast i have time
to change my mind 50 times but right now
i'd say i'd pick the bills to win
yeah i mean i i do think there's a lot
of ways they they match up with
pittsburgh and you know especially
we've talked about the weakness of
buffalo and go oh with the run defense
well that's looked a little bit better
lately and pittsburgh doesn't run the
football so that that's that's okay
that's kind of a plus for buffalo there
and then on the other side of the ball
man i don't know i pittsburgh has not
played a passing attack like josh allen
and the buffalo bills yet that's what
i'm going to be interested to see here
going forward i really am
um i i think that i'm still not totally
confident in the cover guys of
pittsburgh when there is time to throw
and things like that like we saw at the
end of the game
you know pittsburgh is not real deep on
the defensive line either
and without bud dupree that's one less
guy one less stud one less
you know body a part of the rotation
that is something that worries me about
them as we go down the stretch here
you know who's going to be that team
that
does to them like new england used to do
you know new england used to play the
pittsburgh steelers and come out and do
hurry up offense
and they did it for one reason because
they were gonna wear out that front four
in that rush they weren't gonna let them
be a factor in the football game in
third and fourth quarter
they would be dead by that you know i
would think at some point one of these
teams does that is a buffalo
i don't know but i have my concerns
about pittsburgh that way
and how they can match up against high
octane offenses
well and think about what we saw the
bills do to the 49ers on monday night
you've got a quarterback who can buy
time with this guys you've got receivers
who are going to get open
it could look a lot like it did frankly
on monday night that that may be the
formula for a team like the steelers
because
you can wear out their pass rush that
way they're lacking
but dupree and and they don't have
tremendous
they've got good good better than it
used to be that's right but they don't
have tremendous
talent in the back end right that that's
what that's what i think is you know
because even we saw the other night i
mean there's some moments where okay
ma'am now we got to play some man-to-man
and do things like that
oh wow all right we can't cover that guy
or this guy
oh wait now we got a blitz and oh okay
our blitz you know we're trying to rush
five it's not getting there quite as
quickly because it's late in the game
we're a little tired oh man now there's
some holes in our zone there's you know
jd mckissick running and all that but
really that's the intriguing thing to me
with pittsburgh still very impressed not
trying to take anything away from them
pittsburgh fans
but they i don't think they have not had
to play a team that has a legit
big time quarterback legit passing
attack
all season and i want to see that
because it's always been a question
over the last few years we know we've
had this conversation a lot
and i think sunday night will go a
little bit further in just giving us a
little more information about
how real how how good is pittsburgh that
way
if they shut them down it'll make me
think differently of them but
i don't know if i feel that way sitting
here on wednesday the steelers had held
the number one spot in the power
rankings for six weeks here's a question
from t-shirt
university i know the steelers have only
one loss but if the playoffs started
today do you think they would make it
to the afc championship now if the
playoffs started today they'd be the one
seed
so they'd only need to win one game
divisional round
at home to get to the afc championship
we don't know who that would be
but let's assume it would be anyone in
the field other than the chiefs it could
be the bills it could be the ravens
it could be the browns do you think the
steelers
right now would win a divisional round
game at home against one of these
second-tier teams in the afc yeah i mean
the the one thing is when you i mean the
way it stands as of right now the
divisional round game they won't have to
play kansas city or buffalo
so it would be a tennessee well it could
be buffalo oh that's right well
well buffalo's gonna have to win but
then buffalo would be playing the chiefs
you're right yeah right
right so i mean just how that kind of
looks that way to where
you know the the positive thing there i
think is
after you know the chiefs in buffalo i
don't know if there is that high octane
offense that could scare their secondary
and do that you got a lot of
you know defense can run the ball
cleveland miami
tennessee so yeah i do
i think if that it stands this way i do
look at it and go they can get to the
afc championships game is it concerning
of course it is
you know if they have to win more than
one game to go to the afc championship
game of course it's more concerning
i don't think it's sustainable to keep
winning or go to the super bowl or the
afc championship game with the way
they're playing right now the formula
as far as no run game you know think
about the game the other night
how it bites them in the butt shotgun
shotgun pass pass pass pass pass
oh now we're on the one-yard line oh now
we're gonna get underneath the center
and smash it in there from one no you're
not
you're not that's crazy that's where
they have to start to develop
some sort of diversity there to help
them out oh you know i mean it'd be like
asking you
hey you know you haven't been in court
in a long time yeah i know you could get
through
and you could probably get through the
process and do it but you're not going
to do it to like the best of your
abilities because you haven't been doing
it for a long time well the same with
them
when you throw it 50 times a game there
is no attitude there is no firing off
the ball and keeping your shoulder pads
low and doing all that stuff
and they have to do that i think against
the better teams if they want to get to
the super bowl
there's another comment not a question
from at steelers outpost
observing that the steelers have had a
terrifying regression of their offensive
line and their receiver's ability
to catch and we we had the sound earlier
from mike tomlin talking about the
inability of players to catch and
they'll be replaced by those who can the
offensive line at least from a run
blocking standpoint not good
chris how much of this potentially flows
from and i'm spitballing here yeah
we always tend to do you talked
yesterday about the possibility based
upon what you're gleaning from watching
the game right ben roethlisberger is
changing run plays to pass plays
as a receiver if when you walk up to the
line of scrimmage thinking it's a run
play and it gets changed to a pass
does that mess with you does that does
that make it does it i mean can
i guess you get used to it after a while
you guys doing it all the time
eventually you figure
i better be ready at any given moment i
think this is going to be a run but he's
going to change it to a pass so i better
be ready to catch the ball
but even from the blocker's perspective
if you're going up to the line of
scrimmage thinking that you're going to
be firing off the ball
run blocking instead you're past
blocking i mean
does that uncertainty that that constant
uncertainty of what the play is actually
going to be does that
factor into your performance well you
don't ever like to do too much thinking
at the off on the line of scrimmage you
know you don't want to all the time be
thinking think and change wait what am i
doing ha ha you know
really good offenses you know yeah
they're going to have their moments
where hey
quarterback's going to sit there and
figure out the right play in a certain
situation
but the really what good ones are going
to get in there
have a tempo about them you know some
pre-stat
movement and not let the defense kind of
hunker in there
and think about all the things they can
think about oh wait when they're in the
shotgun and they do this here's the
rolodex of things coach told me to think
about
you know when you have an offense that
gets up to the line of scrimmage
movement
tempo said hut you can't think of those
things
let alone okay because you're you know
the huddle hey
strong left strong left hey oh no you're
making calls and all of a sudden it's
like okay set hut i got to make a play
now
to where the other way around yeah
you're the defense you get to kind of
okay wait all right
coach said when they're an empty they
like these past patterns i got to watch
out for this guy
over the middle you get to check that
out and also what you do in that is yeah
you you take away your offensive line's
ability to just be aggressive and fire
off the football
now they're kind of on their heels
they're always thinking it's always a
little different that way
um they're a great pass protecting o
line in pittsburgh i mean they are great
at that
and then with the drops hey they'll
clean it up you know they have played
two good defenses in a row and i know
some of the drops are inexcusable you
can't say anything about that
but i will say this i i know i said this
to you after the game
when you throw that many short passes
and
it's over the middle and always in
traffic and every time you catch it it's
a bam bam bam play
well damn i i mean they're not superman
or iron man
they're gonna drop it every now and then
that's just when you throw it 51 times
and
48 of them are five yards in the middle
of the field then yeah receivers are
gonna drop the ball in those scenarios
so
there's some issues to clean up i know
we're both still positive about the
steelers but
yeah there's some issues for our 11-1
football team
i want to get your thoughts on the
second half of our top
ten the rams are now number six they
moved up two spots after beating the
cardinals
the dolphins move up two to number seven
after beating the bengals
the browns jumped three and i finally
did it i jumped the browns over the
colts even though the colts won
the browns who have beaten the colts
that's right and i
should have done it last week but this
week with the browns their impressive
victory over
the tennessee titans they're now number
eight so it's rams dolphins browns cult
seahawks down to ten titans on the
outside looking in at the top ten are
you okay with those
six i i am okay with that i mean it is
it's a tough stretch of teams there
because there's you know the the top
five we've seen consistency
throughout the year for the most part
these teams every time we think oh
they're a top five team or they're this
there's always that loss or that
unimpressive game that they play where
you go oh
wait how good are they or they're just a
little inconsistent but i think
i think clearly the rams i would put at
number six
you know i i would i know hey if you
take away the two 49ers games
the rest of their season looks pretty
damn good it really does to where you go
man they can play with anybody they're
tough as hell and even those 49ers games
it wasn't like they were blown out or
anything like that
but after that i'm with you how much did
you
think about the titan seahawks at 10 and
11 just to round out your top 10 there
that must have been pretty close between
10 and 11.
yeah yeah look because the seahawks uh
they lost to a much lesser team yeah
than the titans did and i i did i gave
that a little bit of thought
but uh it was hard putting the seahawks
out of the top ten because
i'm willing to treat what happened on
sunday
like an aberration and maybe that's be
because i was
influenced by the very smooth and suave
effort by russell wilson to explain away
what happened
uh after the game i still i still was
very impressed
by how nonchalant he was about the whole
thing that occurred but uh maybe i still
believe that the seahawks
are an elite team and uh they didn't get
rolled the way the titans did even
though the titans did show some grit and
coming back
let's get a concern from bewildered eric
about
his dolphins at number seven is the
dolphins lack of a true number one
running back going to be their downfall
chris
i think it will be especially if like
two is your starting quarterback
i think that there is a little bit more
needed
at that position of course you know
they're banged up i mean
that's another issue it's like every
time one of them seems to get in a
groove or something
one gets hurt but with the style of
football they want to play
uh with tua which is defense you know
he takes his one-on-one shots on the
outside the boots like we talked about a
few quick throws here and there hey he
looked better in the pocket last week
doing some good things
but i i still don't think we're at the
point with tua to where
we want to get in a play-off game or a
big football game and go
okay you know we're just going to uncork
it and let you throw the ball all over
the field and you'll dissect defenses
and do all that
so it is a little bit of a concern the
lack of running back and run game
at times there in miami the upcoming
schedule a concern for k
mccarra dolphins scheduled to finish we
most likely need to go
two and two to make the playoffs let's
take a look at the dolphins upcoming
schedule
uh i i like i've been impressed by what
they've done all year they've had some
great wins they dismantled the rams
which was impressive
but this is not an easy
kick this is not an easy final four
chiefs pat's at raiders at
bills they probably do need to win two
of them i don't know that one and three
is going to get you in and i don't think
one and three is the way you
want to finish the season but man they
could create some shock waves by
beating the chiefs and yeah the patriots
not long ago look like an easy w there's
not going to be anything easy about it
i think the one game i feel the most
strongly about them winning is the
raiders
i could see them beating the patriots
and the raiders and losing to the chiefs
and the bills and
i don't know maybe that'll be enough to
get in it should be yeah i mean i would
think 10 and six
is gonna make it i mean you know again
we're we're
still too far out just with the fact
that the dolphins the colts
the raiders the baltimore ravens are all
still there six and four i mean eight
and four and seven and five
but man that is some stretch of games um
their defense can be special with their
coaching of course and some of their
talent
i i would think they can give kansas
city some issues this weekend
with their corners and secondary and of
course we know brian flores has some
knowledge of that kansas city offense
and all that
they could be a pain in the butt i mean
we're talking yeah one mistake by kansas
city
you know or something like that all of a
sudden we're going whoa this is going to
come down in the end
and be a close football game i got faith
in them but
as it sits here right now at eight and
four
like what's your gut with that schedule
do you think they're gonna make it and
get in
when you consider all these other teams
and you look at what the
the ravens showed us last night now
seven and five after getting the victory
over the cowboys
i think it's not going to be easy for
the ravens to hold it for the dolphins
excuse me to hold that sick spot
right now i hate to say it because i
like to see change and i
love what brian flores did last week in
defending his guys and
i would have taken brian flores over any
of the members of the cincinnati bengals
organization including all of the
players
i have a feeling they're not going to
make it i i it does
i feel that way too i guess i lean that
way i'm rooting for
it um hey i guess one good thing is you
know they
they got the raiders and colts who play
each other this weekend that's one team
that
you know they're kind of there's two
teams they're fighting with so one of
them is going to lose but
yeah as it sits here right now i think
i'm with you i just look at their
schedule
you know and i feel like they're going
to be on the outside sit
looking into i'm still not giving up on
baltimore i just think baltimore is
going to make a run here
and i would be shocked if baltimore
doesn't win out and they could very
easily be 11 and 5. so i'm still
counting them as a playoff team when
it's all said and done here
one of the most fascinating teams for me
and this team didn't play this weekend
the tampa bay buccaneers at seven and
five with four games to go
the concern expressed by mikeness
mikenis18 for the bucks i worry about
the inconsistency of the offense
and the clash of views between tom brady
and bruce arians and
bruce aryan spoke to reporters yesterday
after several days of not
speaking because they were in their bye
week it's still the same
what a shock he hasn't changed
dramatically from last week to this week
what a stunner
that a guy in his late 60s hasn't
undergone a dramatic personality change
in a short period of time but
you that that that undercurrent is still
there they need
to get the ball to ronald jones 20 times
a game
uh you know they just need to do better
on third downs
on on offense it's it's there wasn't a
sense that he went back to the lab
and realized that there were some major
changes that needed to be made for a
team that when you look at it suggest
that maybe some major changes need to be
made
chris well i mean i think you know our
twitter user there and the question i
think is very real i mean that's that's
the issue
you know with at mikeness18 you know
that's he's right
there seems to be that issue of you know
clash of styles or philosophies there
that they still haven't found
the right formula or way they want to do
it um
i i'm with bruce arians in the fact that
you know i think the bucks are the best
when they do run the ball and play
through ronald jones a little bit
and honestly i think brady looks the
best when they play that way too that's
where i'm a little like
that's where i'm confused about it in
some ways too because i want to be like
man
doesn't brady just see how effortless
the offense is when they
run the ball and he gets to throw the
ball and play action wide open to people
and makes big throws down the field you
know does he really want to
spread it out and try to jam in five and
six yard completions all the time
you know i don't know if that's do i
don't think that's his best thing right
now i don't we're seeing tom brady
when he's in the shotgun people are
starting to blitz him
and pressure him and he doesn't have all
the answers he had in new england and
everything like that
that he is being affected by it and when
they keep tight ends and run the ball
and do all that
he seems comfortable in the pocket and
wants to throw the ball down the field
so uh i don't know where it goes but i i
know i've been pretty steady in the fact
that i think that's their best way to
win and that's the best bucks team
i see when they play with that style and
coming up this weekend against the
vikings team that
yeah they're six and six but but if they
win
they're seven and six and the bucks are
seven and six and the vikings hold the
tiebreaker
this is a perfect defense for tom brady
to be the old tom brady against no
pass rush up the middle right over
matched secondary when you've got
antonio brown and mike evans and chris
goblin and rob gronkowski and if eric
kendricks doesn't come back
from the calf injury that was aggravated
made him a late scratch on sunday
against the jaguars
i mean the vikings have been barely
beating not good
teams the recipe is there sunday for the
buccaneers to just blow the vikings off
the field i mean let's be
objective and let's be realistic if the
buccaneers do what they're capable of
doing
they should roll up 35 to 40 points
chris
i i don't see yeah mike i'm with you i
don't see this as being a good matchup
for
for the vikings you know and and as we
always know i mean the vikings are such
a run centric team too
i just would be shocked if they can run
the ball on tampa bay
i i would and we know like the ripple
effects of that that the
pass offense is not that diverse when
the run game doesn't work to where it
can just carry the squad
so yeah i do think tampa's clearly in
the advantage in this matchup
without a doubt and i would think that
they do win the football game
unless you know brady or just something
stupid happens where they make mistakes
and kind of blow it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports